The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: In a
minute, we're going
to go through this exercise
of key concepts for the week.
But for you early
birds, I'll offer,
and we may get to some of this.
Is there just something from
the weak or the problem set?
Just some topic that's
still bugging you
that you just
don't get and you'd
like me to put on a little
list and I might get to it?
AUDIENCE: So if we
solve for velocity,
is it enough to
just take the time
derivative of that velocity.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So if you have all of the
terms, the full velocity
expression in vector
notation, and you
want to know the
acceleration of that point,
just take the derivatives taking
care of all the rotating unit
vectors and all that stuff.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you take the
derivative of the velocity,
where does the Coriolis
term drop from?
PROFESSOR: Where
does it fall out of?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I can't
answer it in words.
I can't remember exactly.
But Coriolis term--
curiously, it
comes from two different places.
It's two omega v
rel kind of term.
And actually, it comes
from two different places
when you grind out the
derivatives of the velocity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So in terms of using
the general-- so I remember.
Now what I want you
to do and, partly,
what this session
is going to do is
get you to use the
acceleration formulas enough
that you have those just
committed to memory.
Now we're going to let
you have crib sheets when
you go into quizzes.
And I would always have the
velocity and acceleration
formulas in polar coordinates
and in full vector form.
If you identify each
of the terms correctly,
that formula will
work just fine.
Getting the right
components of rotation rates
can be a little
tricky, as you might
have found in that homework
problem from this week.
In that time derivative
of a rotating vector,
the omega cross the vector.
What omega is that?
That's tricky.
That you have to
be careful with.
But really remember.
If you remember the velocity
and acceleration equations,
you can trust them.
They will work.
So OK, we can start now.
And I'll go back to here.
So take that minute,
like we did last time.
Write down on a piece of
paper two, three, four.
What you think are
the key concepts
that were important
in the past week.
By important, you need to
know them to do a good job
on the quiz coming up.
Important concepts.
OK, let's make a list.
AUDIENCE: Did you say
polar coordinates?
PROFESSOR: Polar coordinates.
And I'm going to
generalize that to call
it choosing coordinate systems.
There's an art to that.
So when you to use them.
It's [INAUDIBLE] of that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The equation
for some of the parts?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
The torque equation.
Some of the external
torques vectors is dh/dt.
And torques are always
with respect to some point.
So dh/dt.
Angular momentum is with
respect to some point.
And there's a second
term to this, though.
And it is velocity of the
point in the inertial frame
cross the linear momentum
in the inertial frame.
That one, you haven't
had to use much yet.
But that's one of the two
really important Newton law kind
of things that we
use in the course.
Sum of forces equals
mass times acceleration.
Sum of torques equals that.
OK, I have another one.
AUDIENCE: Derivative of
rotating unit vectors.
PROFESSOR: Derivative
rotating vectors.
And taking derivatives rotating
vectors always boils down to,
eventually, it's down to you
got to do the unit vector.
So that's part of it.
How about another one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so I'll
generalize that to,
essentially, being able to
find equations of motion.
So from sum of forces
and-- all right.
OK, anything else?
I'll tell you one really
important one that you've been.
Maybe you think we
did it last week.
I'd say being able
to find accelerations
and moving coordinate systems.
We did mostly
velocities last week.
But finding velocities
and accelerations
in rotating and moving frames.
OK, so that's a
pretty good list.
[INAUDIBLE] ask me what I
thought the important things
from the week were?
That hits the important stuff.
OK.
What we were talking about
as people were arriving is
and I might not get this
today if we run out of time.
But does anybody just
got a burning question
about some concept that
just didn't work out for you
or a problem set that came up?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The derivatives
for [INAUDIBLE] vectors
and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that's really
the derivative of rotation rate
vector.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That was,
kind of, a nasty problem
the first time you hit that.
That was new, right?
Let me write that one down.
And rotating frames
and all that.
I get it.
Does somebody else
have another one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of that. [INAUDIBLE]
just like which omega is it
when you're looking [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Oh, yeah.
Right.
OK, anybody else a
burning question?
I think I'm actually
going to start there.
We're going to spend just
a minute on this one.
And as an example problem
yesterday in the lecture,
I basically did the same.
I had a rotor here.
It could have a disk on
it just to make it clear.
So this thing is
rotating at some omega 2.
And it was on a merry go
round going at some omega 1.
And I'll pick at
coordinate system here.
I think it was yxz that I
wrote in the lecture notes.
And that's the rotating one.
So you have an o and an a here.
And you have a fixed
frame that but the y
ones, the little ones,
attach to the platform.
It's going around.
OK?
So the rotation rate of
the platform here is what?
In magnitude and unit vector.
Pardon?
Mega 1 k hat.
And does it matter which k
because they're parallel.
So the little k and the big k.
OK, what's the rotation
rate of this shift,
in terms of a magnitude
and a unit vector?
AUDIENCE: Omega 2
lower case y dot.
PROFESSOR: OK, omega 2.
And I'll call it at j1 here.
It's hard to distinguish
my handwriting on the board
between uppers lowers.
So with z1's, x1's.
OK, so it's in the
J1 direction, right?
And I've just intentionally
made it positive.
If it were in the other
direction, have a minus there.
OK, so now at the
end, the problem
asked for the time
derivative of the rotation
rate of the spinning.
The problem that
in the homework,
this thing was actually
inclined, basically.
It's easy to just say the total
rotation rate of the shaft.
Let's get that settled first.
In the fixed inertial frame,
the total rotation rate of this
is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and you
can sum rotation rates.
So it's omega 1 k
hat plus omega 2 j1.
And I want to take the time
derivative of this omega chafed
total.
So it's d by dt of these things.
So I can start to do that.
So d by by dt is, in this
case, is k change a direction.
No problem.
Could that change?
Could it?
Yeah, sure.
I mean, it could be
accelerating, right.
If it is, then you
get a term here
that comes from this one that
would be an omega 1 dot k hat
plus.
And now we need to take the
derivative of this piece.
All right.
And that's now a
rotating vector.
And we've said that the
derivative of any rotating
vector dq dt is the derivative
of t as if the rotation is 0.
It's its magnitude increasing,
not its direction changing.
Plus omega cross q.
And I've intentionally left
sub-scripts and server scripts
off here because
that's the issue here.
Which ones go where?
All right, so this is
what we need to apply
to taking that derivative.
We took this derivative
and found this term
was what gave us the omega 1.k.
And when taking derivative of
this, what was the answer here?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero because the
rotation rate is omega 1.
You're crossing it.
Well omega 1k crossed
with omega 1k.
That goes with zero.
There's no change in direction.
So we applied this
formula once to this.
Now we're going to
apply this formula here.
So I'll do it this way.
So this is term one.
Term one gave us this.
Term two is going
to give us this.
So take this.
Take the derivative of--
where we go here-- this guy.
Now when I say
this is the-- it's
the partial derivative
of this thing,
ignoring the contribution
from the change of direction.
So it's as if some
rotation were zero.
Which rotation?
Right.
AUDIENCE: Omega 1?
PROFESSOR: Omega 1.
Good.
So what is the answer to this
piece of that derivative?
AUDIENCE: Omega 2.
PROFESSOR: Omega 2
dot what direction?
Same direction, right.
Now we want to apply this piece.
So now the question comes
down plus some omega
cross with the q.
And what's the q in this case?
Two.
So this is omega 2 j1 hat.
That's coming from here.
That's what this piece is.
So now we need what's
crossed with it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: Omega [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm trying to think
of a clear way to help you.
What is causing its
direction to change?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's the one you care about.
What's causing its
direction to change?
What's causing this
thing to come up?
And its direction is changing
because the platforms
are moving.
So it's omega 1.
K cross j.
So k cross j gives you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: K cross j negative i
1 in the rotating frame, right.
So this whole thing.
Omega 1 dot k plus
omega 2 dot j1 plus.
No, this is a minus, actually.
We said, minus omega 1.
Omega 2.
K cross j is i 1 hat.
OK?
And finally, how do
you deal with the fact
if this rotor had been
on an inclined angle?
Some phi, which now this
is the exact problem
that was on homework.
So propose a way
of attacking that.
Changes this problem
just a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Can you change the
reference frame [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, you don't
change the reference frame.
You still have a
coordinate system.
Work with the
coordinates you got.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
to its components?
PROFESSOR: In which
reference frame?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
moving [? one. ?]
That makes it easy
because this thing now
has a vector omega 2 like that.
And you can break it up
into a piece like that
and a piece like that.
So now this is phi.
Omega 2 cosine phi
is the side, right.
Omega 2 sine phi is that side.
What direction is it?
What's its unit
vector direction?
This piece.
AUDIENCE: K?
PROFESSOR: K, OK.
And we're going to end up
crossing it with this term,
right.
So k cross k.
Nothing.
So in fact, this bit
doesn't change in direction
as it's rotating.
Does it?
So it isn't going to
contribute to that second term.
Only piece you have to be
concerned with is this one.
So down in here in this
part of it, all you would do
is say omega 1 k cross.
And now you just put
in the q full omega
2, which is omega 2 sine
k plus omega 2 cosine.
Sorry about the writing here.
And do the cross product.
You find out that
term disappears.
And you get an omega
1 omega 2 cosine.
And this term here
is still the answer.
But you end up with
a cosine phi in here
because it's just the
component of omega 2 that's
in the j1 direction
now that contributes.
OK, great.
Good.
That help?
I'll leave this.
Let's get on to the
problem for the day.
The problem for the day is
you've got a rotating arm.
You have a mass sitting on it.
The arm is rotating at
some rotation rate omega.
You might have an acceleration
omega dot theta double dot.
This mask can slide.
So the problem is this
thing is-- I'll start here.
So it's rotating like this.
And eventually, the
thing begins to slide.
And in fact, if I
do it, this actually
works a little better
here because I have
a little tiny groove in this.
It helps a little bit.
So it's rotating like that.
It eventually begins to slide.
And if the rotation rate
is slow, it slides down.
If I made the rotation rate
fast enough, it slides up.
And the angle at which
it happens clearly
depends on rotation rates,
accelerations, the angle,
friction coefficients,
and things of that sort.
So what I want you to
start with is here's,
basically, a drawing of it.
And I don't want to give
you any excess information.
But what I want you to do
is each, by yourselves,
take just a minute,
and draw a free body
diagram of this problem.
And then, after that, I'm
going to have you get in groups
and improve on it.
But start yourself.
Draw a free body diagram
that will describe
this mask on this thing, plank.
OK, we've got a sketch with a
little free body diagram on it.
What I want you to
do now, we're going
to do this two or
three times today.
Get in groups of four five here.
Compare notes, and come up
with a group free body diagram.
So you're pretty close.
Let me look.
Where was your guys
solution again?
There is maybe about
as good as it gets.
So here's our mass.
I think everybody had an mg.
Almost everybody
had a normal force.
Everybody had a friction force.
Some discussion about what
direction the friction force
ought to be in.
I'll draw it uphill here.
And I'll call it ft
for tangential, here.
So some had about that much.
There's a very important
missing piece, which
actually several groups had.
What is that?
Can anybody guess what I'm--
three of your groups had
something on here that I
don't have up here yet.
I hear coordinates.
This one, you can
almost get away
with not putting it in the
coordinate system first.
But you, usually, need to have
a coordinate system in order
to determine the
direction of the forces.
OK?
And we'll get to
that in a second.
So everybody that I saw
had written down, I saw,
a number of the little x,
y, z frames sitting out here
like that.
Maybe one was lined up.
Not sure.
Most not.
Most like this.
Is polar coordinates a good
choice for this problem?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the question is
whether or not r theta and z
can completely describe
the motion in the problem.
AUDIENCE: You have
tangential forces,
so it's better if
you use rectangular.
PROFESSOR: The
radius is changing.
But that's known as r dot.
r dot can handle the
motion to this this way.
r double dot can handle
acceleration this way.
Theta dot can
handle this motion.
Theta double dot can
handle that acceleration.
Actually, is there any
z motion or z-forces?
No.
Actually, the polar
coordinates will actually
work here just fine.
So you definitely have to
pick a coordinate system.
So we're going to have an
that system and theta hat
in this direction
because in this problem,
whether you use x and y as a
rotating frame here or r theta,
you want to pick your coordinate
system so that these things
break down easily.
In this case, the
normal equation
will be in the
theta hat direction.
The sliding direction will be in
just one unit vector direction.
So you don't have multiple
components in this direction.
If you use that coordinate
system to describe this motion,
you have x and y terms.
It makes it harder.
So this is a pretty good
coordinate system to use.
So that's a really
important missing piece
is the coordinate system,
if you don't have it.
And as an aside about free body
diagrams-- free body diagrams,
except my d is
turned around-- how
do you know that the friction
force is in that direction.
You had to assume something.
This is such a trivial problem
you can kind of figure out
in your head.
I gave the demonstration.
It slid down.
But also, I said , you do
it fast enough, it goes up.
So you don't really know.
So you have to have made
an assumption about it.
So the general rule
is to assign or assume
positive values for all motions.
And then, you deduce
the direction of forces.
And I'll take another
quick aside here
to illustrate this in a
problem that works better
than the current one for this.
An obvious coordinate system
for this little mass on rollers
inertial frame.
Here's an x.
And I asked you to do a
free body diagram of that.
Well you would show
me a normal force.
You'd show me an mg.
But now I ask you to
tell me the direction
to draw the spring force.
So if you adopt the
rule that for each body
you're working with, you
assume that it has positive x,
positive x dot, positive
y, positive y dot
then you can deduce what
direction of the forces
would result [INAUDIBLE].
So in this case, the only motion
that generates a force up here
is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Is x. x
dot. x double dot.
The only motion that
will generate a force
is displacement because it
generates a force where?
In the spring.
If they add a dash
[? pod ?] here,
them velocity
generates a force, too.
But displacement, if you assume
the displacement is positive,
then which direction
is the spring force?
OK, so then you have
spring force this way.
And that's value kx.
And when you write it in
the equation of motion,
you put a minus sign to
account for the direction
of that error.
OK.
So in this problem we
kind of-- and if you ever
do it wrong, if you pick
this direction wrong,
what happens in the answer?
Will you still get
the right answer?
If you're consistent, you'll
get another negative sign
popping up to fix it.
OK.
Next.
So I think we're
in good shape now.
I'm going to draw the
friction force uphill
because I'm going to assume this
thing's going to slide down.
And I'm going to simplify the
problem a little bit for you.
And I'm going to
say that there's
no angular acceleration.
Constant angular rate.
The distance that the mass
starts off up the slope
is at one and a half feet.
So it's going up like this.
And it, eventually,
reaches 50 degrees.
And at 50 degrees, it
begins to slide downhill.
So it's going up a constant
rate and starts to slide.
So there must be some
friction coefficient
that provides a system
with a property such
that it slides at 50 degrees.
So the problem here is define
the coefficient of friction.
So now you're in your groups.
Solve the problem.
And what I really want you to do
is come up with an expression.
mu equals in variables
and constants.
Don't bother plugging
in numbers in that.
Well if you're comfortable
using polar coordinates,
that'd be the way to do it.
But you need to write
some equations now.
And I suggest you need to
think in terms of equations
[? in ?] motion.
I think it's time to come back
together here and work on this.
Two, three, or four groups are,
sort of, struggling with this.
And it's because
you're not really
going to first principles and
doing the problem step by step.
You're, sort of,
jumping to the answer
because it's a trivial, simple,
Mickey Mouse problem that you
did in high school.
So I'm, kind of, pounding
on you a little bit.
We give you a simple
problem so we can do them
in a short period of time.
But you need to learn to
do them in the rigorous way
so that you learn the real
fundamental stuff that you
have to know.
So none of you-- you all
are sort of thinking about,
well, we got sum
of the forces here.
We've got an acceleration there.
But nobody is just
sitting down and saying
that some of the forces
is equal to the mass
times the acceleration and
working the problem out.
OK, bad dog.
Just because this problem is
almost the statics problem
doesn't mean you-- when
things are statics problem,
it just means that
acceleration goes to 0.
And the sum of the
forces is now 0.
And you solve the problem.
Start with Newtons, in this
case, it's Newtons second law.
It helps to know an
expression for acceleration,
so you don't have
to grind it out.
So polar coordinates works
pretty well in this problem.
And I want you to commit
to memory two acceleration
equations.
One in polar coordinates, and
the one the general vector 1.
So in polar coordinates,
the one that I memorize
is a with respect to o plus
r double dot minus r theta
dot squared r hat plus r theta
double dot plus 2 omega r
dot theta hat.
Coriolis, Eulerian centripetal,
and your linear acceleration.
What's this term?
What's it doing there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but the
reason I remember it is,
in this course, we break
down every dynamics problem
we're confronted with
into sub problems that
can be solved as the
sum of a translation
of a body plus a rotation.
So this expression
allows you to write down
the acceleration of a
point on a body, which is
both translating and rotating.
What this term accounts for.
The acceleration
contributed by what?
So I've got this
general-- let's see.
I got a merry go
round that's on wheel
and is rolling along here.
And I have an inertial frame.
And I got a point a here.
But now I've also
got a system in here,
which I'm describing with an
r theta connected to this.
Thing can have
translational acceleration.
That's that term.
This problem doesn't
happen to have that.
It goes to 0.
In this problem, that's a 0.
In this problem, we can
now apply this equation
to that problem.
How many sub equations
are we going to get?
And why no three.
AUDIENCE: But I said two.
PROFESSOR: I know you said two.
But I'm asking why not three.
AUDIENCE: Because
[INAUDIBLE] theta.
PROFESSOR: And a z, which you
need because it describes theta
dot.
So you have a z direction.
But is there any forces in this
problem in the z direction?
Are there any accelerations
in the z direction?
No, so you get a
trivial answer there.
So you could just
write that one down.
Mass times acceleration
equals zero.
And there's no forces.
So there's three
possible equations.
Only two of them are
meaningful in this problem.
And we have one that we can
summon the that component
and one in the theta hat.
So the sum of the forces
in the theta hat direction
for this problem are what?
From your free body diagram.
AUDIENCE: The normal force?
PROFESSOR: The normal
in the positive theta
hat direction and?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Minus mg.
And I think it's
[? percosen ?] theta.
And that's your theta hat.
And what is the acceleration
in that direction?
Well you go to
acceleration formula.
And now it's inspect the terms.
This one is 0 because
the platform is fixed.
r double dot?
0 because we're just waiting.
It's just trying to calculate
when it begins to slide.
r theta dot squared.
Not 0.
r theta double dot.
Well it might be.
But I said omega
dots 0 constant.
So that one's 0
for this problem.
And this term, Coriolis.
0 because our dot is 0.
We're really treating this
like a statics problem.
It hasn't started to move yet.
So we're only left
with one term here.
So the sum of the forces in
the normal direction, which is
the theta hat direction are 0.
And that allows us to
solve for the normal force.
So you need Newton's law to find
the normal force to start with.
And you need the normal force
to find the friction force.
So now let's do the sum of the
forces in the that direction.
And maybe, let's do
the acceleration first.
It's the mass times
the acceleration
in the that direction.
And that's the mass.
And now, what's
the acceleration?
These are the r directed terms.
We have one term, right.
Minus r theta dot squared.
No other terms.
And those are going to be
equal to the external forces
in the radial direction.
And what are they?
From the [INAUDIBLE] diagram.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Plus or minus?
AUDIENCE: Plus.
PROFESSOR: Plus mu n.
But we know n is
mg cosine theta.
OK, what else?
Minus mg sine theta.
All right.
You know everything
in this expression.
You know given theta dot.
You're given r.
You know mg.
You know [INAUDIBLE]
given theta.
You could solve this
expression for mu.
All right?
And the mg goes
to the other side.
And you have a minus
r theta squared.
Notice the M's cancel all
the way through, right.
So mu would looks
like it equals, to me,
g sine theta minus r theta dot
squared all divided by what?
g cosine theta.
Break these two
apart, this gives me
a tan theta minus r theta
dot squared over g QoS theta.
That has units of acceleration.
g has units of acceleration.
This is dimensionless.
The answer has got
to be dimensionless.
So there's your answer.
But you really had to use
the equations in motion.
OK now there's
another thing I want
to dress because I heard it
pop up two or three times.
Do not confuse
accelerations with forces.
Newtons second law
makes it really clear
where each one goes.
The sum of the external forces
go one side of the equal sign.
The mass times the
acceleration goes on the other.
Don't get the two mixed up.
Solve for the
accelerations, if you can.
Plug them in.
And multiply them by mass.
And now you have that
one side of the equation.
The free body diagram.
The only vectors that should
show up on a free body diagram
are what?
AUDIENCE: Forces.
PROFESSOR: Forces.
The real forces in the problem.
So in that problem
that free body diagram,
there is no r theta
dot squared term.
It doesn't belong there.
And it'll keep you from
making these sign errors
and things like that.
So the business about
this thing comes up minus
because it's minus right out
of the acceleration equation.
All right, what would happen
if I had not made the-- we're
a go?
This term 0.
I allow this to have some
angular acceleration to it.
That's what's got to happen to.
Well you don't have to do it.
I can't do it constant rate.
But if you can make this
constant rate fast enough,
it goes up.
So even if it's constant
rate fast enough,
this thing will slide up
the thing, immediately,
when you start it.
Almost immediate.
You start down here, the g.
The friction force
is pretty high.
And the friction
force, of course,
diminishes as you
get further up.
And eventually, it
takes off, right.
That's because
that minus r theta
dot squared, that's a
centripetal acceleration
inwards.
And if you don't
provide the force that
causes that centripetal
acceleration to happen,
it says, it says I
want to leave town.
Now how about, though, if I had
angular acceleration, as well?
If I allow angular
acceleration to this problem,
how does it change the two
equations that we wrote?
What does it change?
Does it change the forces?
Does it change the
free body diagram?
Not a bit.
It changes the acceleration side
of the equation and what term
it now turns up that
you didn't have before.
This one.
So now you have a dynamic term
in the theta hat equation.
And it comes into
this expression
for some of the forces
in this direction.
And you would end up equals
to m r theta double dot.
Now it's a entirely
different problem.
It gets a little
harder to solve.
OK, but really good
fundamental practices.
f equals ma.
And write out both
sides carefully.
And then, you won't make
sign mistakes and so forth.
Thanks.
Good to see you.